a dilapidated hotel room in Benin City
after extensive negotiations two human
traffickers have agreed to meet with us
mercy doesn't want to tell us her real
name she herself wanted to go to Europe
last year she got as far as Libya but
when her best friend died there she
turned back in Nigeria once again a
human trafficker asked mercy to help
recruit young women who want to go to
Europe
tell them the routes they will follow
give them the condition because they
know that I have experience so but I
don't tell them all my experience so
that we have the mind to go as soon as
the young woman's journey begins a man
who goes by the name of Steve takes over
he brings them to Agadez in the sahara
from there another smuggler brings the
women to libya steve profits from his
tight network of contacts he knows when
he has to pay bribes plenty of people
are looking for kickbacks in the process
of smuggling these women from informants
to police we're going to do this you
know because in this business he tells
us Trust has to be important he says
we've known each other since she tried
to travel to Europe herself someone
introduced her to me to help her inform
the two traffickers don't want to say
anything specific about who's backing
them but they do tell us about others
who are making money from this illegal
business we make our way to a juju
temple in Benin City many traffickers
bring their human cargo to places of
worship like these before heading to
Europe inside the juju temples the women
are made to swear to pay back all their
debt
the smugglers often demand 30000 euros
or more to bring them to Europe the
priest doesn't want to confirm anything
on camera but he does say that the gods
will take revenge should a juju oath be
broken once he demanded [ __ ] we die if
you stay with dad under seven days you
die right Rhonda the smuggler Steve gets
600 euros per woman for the journey to
Agadez when we meet him on the border
Tunisia about 500 kilometers from Agadez
he tells us that the journey through the
desert is especially dangerous he tells
us people might be robbed or attacked or
sometimes even killed in the desert he
says you can be robbed and ladies can be
raped and besides if you are alone in
the desert and your car breaks down many
people usually die on the road because
there is no chance of any help Steve
says that he rarely feels any remorse
about the kind of work he does he brings
the women safely to their destination
and then his job is finished